L'administration plante haver
dit à l'époque, souvenez-vous,
il ne me reste, sur notre
qu'on voulait faire.
Ça a été annoncé aujourd'hui
comme nous le dit Jacquaudrey
Charbonneau.
- On ne veut plus
quststststststststststststststsu
faire de plus quand Maria
est décédée? Me  : : :
mon enfant passe par
ce chemin-là, puis c'est ça
que je fais, moi. On me félicite
d'envoyer mon enfant
à l'abattoir.
- Cettnénénée, donc, dans
les dernières années, on a
sécurisé... des tous petits
et petites.
Ce programme-là, ce qu'il vient
faire, c'est qu'il permetentre e
des dos d'âne, des saillies
de trottoir, d'élargir
les trottoirs, ds.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Ça peut être aussi des voies
cyclables.
- C'est évidemment une super
bonne nouvelle pour nous.
On a très hâte que ça soit mis
en placersrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrsrs
d'école.
- Nous, ce qu'on demande aussi
par contre, c'est pas juste
des mesures ponctuelles autour
des écoles, mais c'est aussi
un plan global d'apaisement
du transit.
- C'est danger, , , , , c'est
dangereux là, même c'est même
dangereux dans nos petites rues.
On ne peut pas passer
tous les jours, tous les jours,
tous les jours...
- Le midi, en 90 minutes,
j'ai compté 62 infractions.
Puise e e e e e e e e e e e e ee
actuel, les enfants ne sont pas
en sécurité, moi, je ne su
en sécurité.
- C'est toujours une bataille,
obtenir un brigadier
dangereux. Ça demandedededededee
de la mobilisation.lilililililii